[Music]
i'm not exactly sure how many jeans i
own the numbers probably close to like
12 or 13 between like 25 and 35 i think
i own about 30 40 pairs of jeans
hey what's up everyone this is gq
recommends and today we are going to
talk about jeans
[Music]
how often do i wear jeans
i mean
i
wear jeans every day unless i'm going to
like a funeral or something they're
endlessly versatile and go with
everything you own
gene fits exist on such a wide spectrum
all of our bodies are different so all
of our genes to be different as well
the straight leg jeans are the original
cut of jeans the levi's 501 the holy
grail of all jeans that is the gene that
invented jeans the 501 is probably the
place to start it's
a straight silhouette and there's no
like narrow
taper or anything it's not too tight
it's not too relaxed the rise which is
to say like how high or low the waist
goes is usually like a what we would
call a mid-rise
a pair of like really classic straight
leg jeans feel to me so much like that
greaser movement i love to throw a denim
jacket on top and go full canadian
tuxedo i am canadian so it's my
birthright wear tough pair of boots with
them just wear a classic white t-shirt
with them
denzel looking like a king at the
airport this is a great example of how
these jeans can dress up or dress down
you throw them on with a t-shirt you
throw them on with a jacket they look
just as killer
it's pretty easy to dress up a straight
leg i mean how i would do it is probably
like a blazer maybe a button-up shirt
maybe even like denim on denim like with
a western shirt and a blazer there are
some photos of harrison ford looking
great
if you're looking to buy a pair you're
on a budget the best place to start is
levi's they invented the american blue
jean or you could try a brand like left
field it's really hardy it's really
tough it looks like the jeans that james
dean would have worn in the 50s if
you're really trying to get freaky and
trying to step things up then you can go
to a japanese label like capital they
are the be-all and end-all of artisanal
denim with interesting colors with
interesting weaves it's
just
it's
[Music]
art flare jean is a very 70s style it's
a very sort of like rock and roll it
feels very retro these days i think
flare kind of covers or encompasses
several different categories you have
the boot cut which is made for like
putting over a cowboy boot and then you
have the bell bottom 70 or style which
can get like crazy
i like to wear flare jeans with black
chelsea boots which looks really classic
but i also like to just wear them with
you know zomba sneakers these guys are
all wearing capital hippie jeans which
are basically vintage pairs of denim
patched in this really crazy way to sort
of evoke the style of denim warren by
hippies in the 60s it's really cool when
you can sort of bring into the modern
day by wearing it with jordans i think
that's superfly
jeremy o'haras love jeremy o'hara's i
believe these are gucci jeans they look
amazing that's a flare it's definitely
wider than like a boot cut jean if
you're gonna do a cropped flare do it
like this so you can see the loafer i
wouldn't go any higher than that if you
walk into any good vintage store these
days you'll find a rack of flare jeans
on the runway there's a lot of designers
doing pretty aggressive you know radical
flare silhouettes levi's actually just
reintroduced a flare silhouette that's
high-waisted and has a nice subtle
flared leg i think for flare jeans
wrangler for sure love levi's love a
lemare jean gucci makes a great flared
jean
celine makes a great flair jean if
you're looking to splurge
[Music]
today i'm wearing a pair of slim
straight jeans a trimmed down but
definitely not skinny take on a classic
straight leg these in particular are
vintage levi's 5.0 fries from the early
70s i would say a pretty formal look all
things considered i'm actually wearing
what's called a tie so a slim straight
silhouette is
pretty similar to a straight leg and
think of it as like still a straight
silhouette but a little bit narrower and
generally the slimmer you get the waist
will also be a little bit lower i
wouldn't say they're low rise but
they're usually a little bit lower
than a mid-rise
they sit really nicely over a pair of
sleeker chelsea boots or clean toe
derbies or even classic chucks i would
actually pair this with a more formal
shoe i think they look really great with
a pair of cowboy boots and just a plain
t-shirt i mean if you have a plain white
t-shirt and a pair of jeans you have an
outfit i would generally try to keep the
silhouette up top similar a shirt that's
a little bit more fitted again not like
skinny i would add that if you're
worried about buying a pair of jeans
that will look dated for some reason in
five years you're safe with these they
will
always look timeless because they're not
very timely
every brand has their own slim
silhouette if you're really like i don't
know anything else i'll just go to
levi's you can do that buck mason also
is a little bit more expensive and from
there man like what brand doesn't make
one if you're looking to spend a little
bit more i think a lot of guys will
start to go to apc or 316 or rag and
bone
these are the ramones in a classic slim
straight gene i love how much attitude
they have like how much punkish derision
they have for the man
i think it all comes from the jeans
high-waisted jeans are exactly what they
sound like they sit high on your waist
kind of up to your navel it's a very
late 80s early 90s look it gives you
that like freddie mercury jimi hendrix
type of vibe it kind of elongates your
body it's relaxed but also feels a bit
more like pulled in since it sits up
here
high-waisted jeans being cool again is a
very recent thing i think you'll
remember in like the 2000s early 2010s
low-rise was still a thing right for men
and women we've started to see those
waistlines creep up higher and higher
your waistline is fully on display you
should have a fun belt to show it off
whether that's something really classic
whether that's a little bit thinner
which might be a cool look whether it's
a fun loud color
definitely when you have a high-waisted
jean you should tuck in your shirt i
think you want people to see that it's a
high-waisted jean and it just also
accentuates your figure i like a half
tuck if you're wearing a button down i'm
known to do a half tuck i think if
you're wearing a t-shirt tuck it in
fully for a more accessible jeans like
under a hundred dollars i like
wrangler's dress jean it has like a bit
of a flare it's higher waisted but it
feels more dressy
evan mock this is an amazingly bold look
there's his navel the jeans being that
high like do a lot of the work here
making sure that you're not exposing too
much and yet just that little bit of
skin takes this look to a whole other
level i think i'd love to own these pair
of jeans the detailing in the pockets is
great they're a great fit they're not
too tight around your calves they're
wider at the bottom there's like a two
inch break there which is always great
by the boot
david bowie is
david bowie how could you not love
everything about david bowie yeah he has
a great denim kind of a faded black wash
has a great belt they sit higher waisted
they hug your calf which is awesome yeah
this is a sick look
[Music]
so what are skater jeans i'm not a
skateboarder obviously
skaters tend to wear jeans that are
wider in the thigh it's just easier to
be like active in jeans that are not
tight in the thighs skaters also tend to
wear jeans that are cropped if not super
cropped at least not super long you
don't want too much jean getting in the
way of what you're doing you want to
also show off your sneakers
so in my mind a skater cut is lower on
the waist for sure but it's pretty loose
and fluid probably held up by like a
shoelace belt if anything
funnily enough i think the people who
style skater jeans the best are actual
skaters so at any point south of canal
street you'll see guys in baggy t-shirts
super low-rise sheens and maybe a
trucker hat they naturally lend
themselves towards less formal outfits
although you can certainly pair them
with like a pair of clogs and a really
large double-breasted overcoat and still
look pretty sick
i do have a couple pairs of jeans that
are sort of reminiscent of skater jeans
such as this pair which is quite wide in
the thighs and then you know also a
little cropped it's super adaptable you
know today i'm wearing them with chunky
prada chelsea boots but yesterday i wore
them with loafers i wouldn't wear skater
jeans with like a jacket a button-down
shirt i mostly just wear with t-shirts
so i'm looking at a picture of james
harden wearing a very nicely fitting
pair of skater jeans and he's a huge
sneaker head so it makes sense that he
wants a silhouette that kind of ends
before his shoes james harden makes
these look just so easy as you can see
they're a little paint splattered i'm
not sure if that happened when he was in
the studio i think either way it looks
it looks kind of cool i would also point
out that he's obviously a taller dude
and this makes him look really well
proportioned because they're cropped and
don't put too much emphasis on his lower
half
asap rocky is obviously a style god i
don't think he's ever worn a bad fit and
these jeans are cropped at the hem he's
wearing them with vans it looks like
rocky has a little strand of pearls sort
of serving as a wallet chain i've never
seen that before i think it's incredible
if you're looking for under 100 skater
jeans i'd probably go to levi's in the
roughly 300 range sounds unconventional
but i'd probably send you to supreme
despite the graphic tees their jeans are
super sturdy and will last you for years
[Music]
well thanks for watching all of our
wonderful gene content tune in next time
for whatever else we're going to talk
about